hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute mit der liebe
zuschauer seien erfolge minecraft das
bin ich
ich bin ja allerdings nicht alleine
sondern mit jetzt sitzen wir zusammen
und haben uns gedacht dass wir zusammen
minecraft spielen schnix wichtiger da
bist du im internet
ich habe euch letzten sinn der
installateure gefragt was ich mal wieder
hochladen soll und so viele von euch die
cutscene offen mich zu schlagen darauf
viele von euch haben wir geschrieben
luca ladner wieder minecraft hoch
seitdem pippa ich glaube ich an
minecraft let's play angefangen hatte
[Musik]
dem pew die preise in minecraft
stalinismus den eigenen baum zurück ich
ewig mein herze größer ich nicht ja auf
jeden fall haben wir viele leute von
euch geschrieben luca ladner wieder
minecraft hoch und ich habe ja mit julia
auch schon bei minecraft gespielt das
ist allerdings bereits fast ein jahr her
da hast du zum ersten mal minecraft
gespielt tatsächlich gut
ein baum hier der ist überhaupt nicht
verändert gefällt ja er brauche ich den
rest ich glaube nicht
die baumkrone der luft herum schweben
oder regal hält es nicht egal umwelt
natur
mainz besitzt übrigens gerade hier links
neben mir
wir haben keine zweite kamera von daher
steht hier leider nur mit wenn ihr
allerdings bock auf dieses projekt habt
und sagt ey das ist ja echt irgendwie
gar nicht mehr so scheiße wenn die
beiden das ja ich habe drei herzen juli
[Musik]
eine brille auf im spiel nicht auch
nicht wenn ihr auf jeden fall bock auf
dieses projekt habe dann können uns ja
auch gedanken darüber machen dass wir
uns irgendwie eine zweite kamera hier
hinstellen dann seht ihr eine
facebook-seite sogar die gegeben die und
ich geb dir noch die hälfte an holz der
kriegs auch freust du dich ja ist doch
selbstverständlich
was die sonne ist kurz auf runterzugehen
wir haben noch nichts erreicht jetzt
schon 25 holz und die fresse du laden
die machen uns jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen kohle und die kohle packe ich
jetzt zusammen mit den stärken so dass
wir ein paar fackeln haben weil dadurch
haben wir hier schon ein bisschen mehr
licht siehst du das ja ja ja gut ja die
scheiße es das jetzt muss da kommt man
sich eigentlich in den fackel
reinstellen ohne zu sterben
ich habe gar nicht hin und guckt du
kriegst direkt schaden oder reingeht
[Musik]
scheiße also wir müssen uns jetzt
wirklich erstmal provisorische hütte
hier bauen
deswegen nehme ich einfach mal das ganze
holz was wir haben und bau das einfach
mal hier rum was dachte wieder eine
chance von einem baum stehen schön hier
ja dann warten wir jetzt mal bis sie
nach vorbei ist ich bin nicht immer
nicht ich habe eineinhalb herzen trat
sie hier nimmt auch eine schere und eine
schaufel das ist das ist gut
[Musik]
was ist hier
ich warte darauf dass ich mal ein
bisschen unserem app erkunden ja
wir sind ja da vorne sind wir gespannt
und wir haben bisher wirklich nur dass
hier erkundet und dahinter der bambus
der formel ist nichts wir können einfach
mal darüber den hügel gehen wenn paar
stunden später ja wir sind jetzt hier
auf unseren berg gegangen und ich dachte
hinter kommt jetzt die große weite welt
aber nein
jule ein halbes herz hier ist wasser
[Musik]
warum dachte ich das ist eine gute idee
ist auf jeden fall haben wir hier auf
der seite unser haus steht nur wasser
und auf der andern seite haben wir auch
noch was heißt ich würde sagen wir
schauen jetzt mal so ein bisschen weiter
ich habe die blöde befürchten ist dass
wir auf einer insel sind jetzt
befürchtung dass ich immer noch nicht
gesehen das ist bienen gibt bienen ja
wirklich sinnvoll süß aus wenn ihr noch
eine zweite folge wollt dann lasst den
daumen hoch da also ich bin jetzt zum
kompletten ende der insel nach links
gelaufen und wir haben hier wirklich
rein gar nichts was uns irgendwie was
bringen könnte nichts das sind
tintenfisch und sonst nur wasser können
wir nicht noch mal an
heute wollen wir uns gegenseitig dann
mal eben okay du bist schon tot
zum glück gar nicht rein hier bei uns so
ich habe jetzt alle sachen die kitze
gepackt genau jetzt bin ich tot und
leute die sache ist es ja wird gar nicht
dunkel wenn man diesen shader drin hat
bei regen die sache ist dass jule und
ich wir bereits merkt überhaupt keine
ahnung haben so richtig von minecraft
also falls ihr uns irgendwie
weiterhelfen können mit denen wir müssen
das jetzt safe zu machen teilt ihr bock
auf dieses projekt habt und bock auf
einen zweiten teil hab mit julia und mir
hier in minecraft beziehungsweise mit
shrek und mainz kindliche hässlich
einfach falls ihr bock auf den nächsten
teil hat dann das unbedingt einen daumen
hoch unter dem video ihr da schreibt uns
zudem gerne tipps und tricks und in die
kommentare und eventuell auch sachen die
wir mal machen sollen
also wir können uns beispielsweise in
der nächsten folge schon bot basteln und
versuchen irgendwo hinzufahren oder die
insel auf der anderen seite vielleicht
erst mal erkunden
sonst würden die heutigen episode in
minecraft mit luca und tools beenden
ja abonniert main kanal lass ich lieber
[Musik]
ein spezieller niemals erzählen